[موسيقى]
شكرًا
لك ، لقد غيّر الوباء الأشخاص والأماكن
من نواحٍ عديدة في إسطنبول ، فقد أدى
إلى البحث عن تلك الأماكن ونموها
حيث يمكننا أن نتنفس بحرية ونفكر بعمق
فقط أن تكون
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
أجنبيًا
مباشرًا أن الكثيرين يأتون في وقت مبكر
ساعات ليس فقط
للاستمتاع بأول ضوء لـ Tranquility of Dawn الذي
يستعد ويطلق يومهم
[موسيقى] ،
إنه مبكرًا ، نعم أي شيء يخرجني والقطط
[موسيقى]
نحتاج إلى البدء مبكرًا لتجنب
حركة المرور البحرية الكثيفة بعد كل هذا
واحد  من أكثر ممرات الشحن ازدحامًا في
العالم ،
هذا الذي أعتقد أنه يسار أو موهرين
هو محامٍ يومًا ما ، لا The Rim
الجزء الأسود ، نعم ويبدأ يومه
هنا مع مجدفين آخرين من
نادي Palat Rowing ، يمسك به ويدفع
ذلك  السبب الرئيسي
الذي يمكن أن يحدث خطأ
لا تقلق ، لا يمكنني السباحة ،
فنحن نبتعد عن القرن الذهبي ،
إنه مدخل لمضيق البوسفور العظيم
الذي يوفر المياه الهادئة
المثالية للمبتدئين ، نعم مثلي
لقد كانوا في التجديف  هنا منذ أن كانت المدينة
لا تزال تسمى القسطنطينية وقبل وقت طويل
من بدء السباق في
بريطانيا وبساقين رائعين ، هذه هي الطريقة التي نريدها
بالضبط قبل أن يتذكر دماغي The
Strokes لكن عضلات ظهري وساقي
تتظاهر بالفعل ولديها  لفعلهم ،
إنه أحد تلك الأشياء التي قمت بها
قبل
أن أعرف أن عضلات الفخذ الخاصة بي ، فإن أوتار الركبة الخاصة بي
ستصرخ غدًا ،
فهي حقًا ليست كذلك ، نعم ،
دعنا نستمتع باللحظة واستمتع
باللحظة التي
قلتها  إنه جميل جدًا
، أريد أن ألتقط هذه اللحظة ، إنه أمر
غير عادي كيف يمكن لمدينة تولد
طاقة غير مقيدة أيضًا أن تخلق مثل هذه
المشاعر الهائلة من
الهدوء ، يا لها من طريقة رائعة لبدء
الصباح ،
لماذا تفعل هذا
أفعل هذا بسبب هذه المدينة الجميلة
لأن  إنها المرة الوحيدة التي تكون فيها
مع المدينة